[Music]  first of the final breaking bad episodes  premiered sunday night everyone's been  talking about how tense and suspenseful  uh these episodes are going to be and  that's why i have to tell you i'm a huge  fan of the show but i was a little  surprised by the newest drug lord  they've added to the cast i really  i don't know i think they could have  done better take a look  [Music]  so  word on the street is you make some  pretty hardcore drugs and stuff like  that  [Applause]  but i'm the drug lord in this desert and  ain't no one must lend in on my  territory  i'll give you 35 of the tape hmm  i hate to play hardball with you but  what about 36.  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  i guess you guys like it